trust me when I say this I know where
the girls are coming from when they say
to decenter men and and that you
shouldn't put any value into what men
think of you or how they treat you
because uh they're dog [__] most of the
time okay I get that and I understand it
the problem I have is as a straight
heterosexual woman who's attracted to
straight heterosexual men and would like
to experience a romantic heterosexual
relationship with a man but has never
had the opportunity to do
so it makes it hard to really accomplish
that and on top of that I am force-fed
content on and offline on a daily basis
seeing women who are truly valued and
treated well by the men in their lives
and that makes me physically ill some of
the time like having content shoved down
my throat of how some women are treated
by the men in their lives and how valued
they actually are and knowing that no
man in my life has ever actually liked
me like at all and has never valued me
literally at
all um it kind of does something to the
psyche and and your self-worth and your
self-esteem no matter how much
self-confidence you have you know every
time I hear people say stuff like yeah
[__] them men men are trash all this
other stuff it just makes me think of
like that kid in school who was rejected
so then they just start hating on their
Crush but they really just likeed them
the whole time you know so they start
being mean to their Crush [__] she's
ugly but deep downside they they want to
slop on that knob they're kids what are
you talking about what the
bro yo you've been wild today you just
pulling out the gay [__] out of nowhere
the slobbing up the knobs the kids
yo anyways let me move on for my
metaphor all this to
say this is a prime example of a hurt
people act like [__] do you see your
face when you do that what that's the
only
yo that's the only reason I do that
because that when you go when
you yeah I'm giving you that just pearly
things look that's that uh 16 year olds
are hotter than 29 year olds yeah that's
that's aunny I'm just saying I'm just
saying that cuz that's a funny thing to
say your face does that and okay careful
just don't make any tweets I'm not going
to make any tweets I'm not it's not
serious and my self-confidence and my
journey with that uh has been a journey
you know and I'm the most confident I've
ever been in my life
so I don't really put up or
accept men who treat me like dog [__]
anymore but then that just leaves me
having no interactions with men at
all all the men you interact with treat
you like dog [__] uh you're probably not
choosing the right h i mean so you do it
something you know what a thing is you
you can't just keep encountering the
opposite sex and they're always the same
way like what does that really say about
men then I I might as well start taking
seriously the guys who meet women
they're like all the women I meet are
gold diggers it's like do we take him
seriously no we would tell him you're
being goofy you're going after a certain
type if you're constantly meeting dudes
are always treating you
badly sometimes I wonder when I talk to
some people sometimes and they're like
all the people I attract are doing that
and I'm like hm all the people you
attract yeah all the people you attract
H is it all the people that you attract
or or or or is it all the people that
you let
in Bally you just say like that and
people you attract no at some point you
entertain them there's other people that
get and I'm just saying General I don't
know this lady so I I I can't know if
maybe all the people you attract but
that's kind of weird if all the people
you attract or dog [__] or treating you
like [__] all I have a problem with that
is it all the people you attract or all
the people you let in all right cuz
there's attracting and then there's
selection there's something that you do
whenever you say that all when you
saying that sentence it's like if you
had nothing to do with it
you were
just present and then this will just
happen to you so the there there's that
I don't think people really understand
it unless they've been in this exact
position
themselves and also the fact
that my connection has to come from
friends and
family whereas those friends and family
already have partners and then they get
their connection from them and then I
get the
leftovers and that feels really [__]
good also literally no amount of
selflove will
replace what a romantic relationship can
do for
people that's an inconvenient sad truth
that I feel like no one on this app
really wants to accept they just want to
shove self Lov down your [__] throat
and individualism down your throat until
you were so sick and tired of it
that you come on this app like I'm doing
right
now and ranting about it I just would
love for a man to see me as the person
that I really am rather than what I can
provide for
him because I realize that's why a lot
of women are in romantic relationships
and Partnerships with men is that they
have this
currency that they can provide for men
this social status and because I'm not
skinny I can't give that to them so okay
just to be clear most of these dudes are
not with skinny women because it's
social currency they're just with these
skinny broads because they just find
them more trct as they type yeah a lot
of men are not going to overlook the
fact that you're overweight you can
choose to do something about it or you
can choose to wait and be patient for
somebody who will does it make your
options Slimmer pun intended yes you
can't look at other people who made the
right choices in regards to their own
body and their health and they' be like
w they're only being valued because
they're skinny no they're being valued
because they're choosing to do something
that's probably more difficult than
being obese the point that you was
making about this app shoving down the
throat that you know self love self love
self love and proning IND individuality
I think that I got to give her that I'm
like yeah it does it that that does that
and people be saying that to you and
they're like mhm no you're good you have
to improve no and you know being in a
being in a couple feels
good ask longing love whatever her name
is what when I'm home he's there for me
yeah I'm sure he is so you got you I I
got to say you're right about that they
don't take the time to see me as a real
person and to get to know me as a real
person cuz they can't your
personality and most people want a
romantic partner they want to if they
don't find you hot they're not trying to
find out what kind of [__] you writing
up in your diary they don't want to see
how intellectually you can over they
don't give a [__] they're not attracted
to you that's their advertisement and
you know what I'm pretty confident that
if you were really not attracted to some
guy and he was making a move on you you
probably wouldn't give him the time of
day either which is fine but same same
that's it same same if I were to lose
150 lbs then they would actually get to
see me as a real person and they would
get to know me as the person but guess
what I'd be still still the same [__]
person
one you probably would be somewhat
different even as a personality but two
yeah that's how it works why when you go
apply for a job and you go to the job
interview you tidy up true why hey just
just just just just why whenever you
have a job interview you go in there and
you're like oh [__] no I can't wear that
they're going to think this I can't wear
this I got to put this shirt I got to
put that and then you sit and you sit
straight and when you give a handshake
you're like if you be sloppy or you just
wear wear regular clothes if you if you
if you wear your regular joggings or
whatever what not you're still going to
be the same you're going to be the same
exact person but but why you you could
be going in the job interview like that
I could be going in the job interview
like that no guarantees we're getting
the job that's true okay no guarantee yo
what's up partner you good I'm so the
make the same dude and I can give the
same service or I I have the same
attribute I know how to work everything
but why so the same thing I guess in the
G dating world you're still going to
come at your best and sometimes your
base of what you have doesn't fit
certain standard I'm pretty sure that if
I go in certain countries I don't fit
the standard that people are going to be
like yeah I'm not going to date you cuz
my parents are not going to approve or
whatever this and that and the third I'm
still me I wouldn't [__] change only
my body will
but then automatically that gives them
value that gives them social
currency even though I didn't
change in here I didn't
change just my body did I just reject
that like changing your body is more
than just changing your body it's an
active self-care it's about how you view
yourself and your own wants and needs
okay and I'm not talking about somebody
who's thick versus somebody who's skinia
I'm talking about people who are like
severely obese like when you take time
to focus on yourself and make that
weight go down and treat yourself well
and you feel physically better it's you
caring for the very thing that makes you
move through life that's not just
changing your body and showing some
level of dedication some level of effort
some level of like I know discipline
like there's a lot of reasons to
appreciate that Beyond just like my body
changed so I don't like the reductionist
attitude that she has in regards to that
cuz most people have had to lose
substantial amount of weight we'll tell
you it is not just a physical thing it's
mental it can often times be spiritual
it the way the whole you move through
life and so many women do that and they
go through that just so that they are
valued and how [__] sad is
that how [__] sad is that but that's
just how the world is that's just you
know you got to play the
game okay nobody was ever going to give
me a chance and see my my beautiful
sword who I was as a person and it's
heartbreaking yeah I mean listen I think
what she said about people always talk
about self-care selfcare on the app and
you know whatever [__] the other gender
all that gender War stuff is mad corny
to me was like we need each other all
this hostility that the genders seem to
have towards each other I just I've lost
my interest in the whole the whole
dynamic um but as far as the individual
goes whether you be a man or woman I
hope everyone makes that effort to take
care of themselves and to do the things
that they can to maximize their own
health and if that leads to better
results in a dating thing that's not a
hypocrisy it's not a bad thing I think
it's um an indication that people who
are dating out here want Partners who
are living a relatively healthy
lifestyle and there's nothing wrong with
that I also say back in the day you
never heard this stuff but back in the
day people weren't as fat as they are
today either and back in the days you
didn't have social media so yeah of
course people you weren't hearing that
stuff as much as much like I I would
look at my mom's pictures from that
generation and like finding an obese
person was incredibly difficult this is
a new thing that's come because of the
fact that obesity has exploded so yeah
people are becoming more strict about
that kind of stuff but is because we
used to already have that standard set
up before no yeah so that's just
something I wanted to add but there's
some people wait wait there's some
people that are actually born in that
world you know we were not born in a
world where there was that acceptance
you understand what I'm saying so
there's some people that are born in
that acceptance and then they turn
around and they're like it's like the
speech doesn't match where we really at
M the speech is like no we should we
should we should and then they're like
yeah we should and then that's good and
then they realize that Oh wait [__] it's
not people are not really accepting the
fact so we were not born in those eras
of acceptance we had to actually change
our minds you understand what I'm saying
they don't she's probably what 21
22 she was born into that she
experienced that born with a phone in
her hand so that's that as well let's
know what you guys think in the comments